a local non-profit is giving to families
dealing with terminal illness this
holiday season angels of Las Vegas
provides food wigs for cancer patients
and more but they can only do it with
your help Candace Charles is at the
facility at Sahara and Buffalo with how
we can help them out during the holidays
good morning Candace
good morning Jerry good morning folks a
moment of generosity really can make a
huge impact on local families and really
it is a simple gesture whether it's
donating or coming to this weekend's
Gala you can help programs like this
continue and I'm watching father thank
you so much for joining me this morning
this is one of the many rooms you guys
have in angels of Las Vegas tell us a
little bit about it well this room is we
use as our art room anytime after 5 PM
on Thursdays and what it is used for is
Art therapy for our patients that are
that are in the hospital or young people
from ages or maybe four years old until
15 years old they'll come in especially
if the ones that are not
um that are residents of the hospital so
they're able to come out on our
outpatients they come out when we do art
therapy right in this room well we're
going to talk a little bit later about
how this all got started which really is
an amazing story but tell us a little
bit more about the work that angels of
Las Vegas do oh my goodness we do a lot
of work a lot of of our work come from
the need of our people of our
neighborhood of our clientele so our
therapy is one of them and we do a
program called feed Vegas so every
Wednesday we're feeding hundreds and
hundreds of families and then we have
self-care programs and a lot of programs
for those who help those who are sick
because they we find that you know
they're the ones that are getting sick
themselves because they're caretakers so
we have lots of different programs to
help them as well awesome I want to say
thank you so much for chatting with us
your Gala is coming up this weekend so
people can come on by and of course if
they can't make it they can donate we'll
have those details on our website
newsnow.com coming up we're going to
tell you how this gal is going to help
all of these programs continue and we'll
also show you the room that started it
all for now live for Angels in Las Vegas
I'm Candace Charles 8 News Now